petit déjeuner justin éthier
françois pérol
j'ai commencéà serait jusqu'à quand
jalouse pas vu la couleur est
extraordinaire c'est des bons chez les
faits dont j'adore ta couleur
[Musique]
à la poste blanche et noire du genou
coup c'est terminé tout leur côté midi
sur le port en noir et blanc toujours
qu'est ce qu'elle est mignonne qu'est ce
que c'est joli ce qu'elle allait elle
est coquette et bien mise à l'écart
c'est tous les jours
elle sera dès dimanche
serait ce qu'en dit voudrait derniers
arrivés
[Musique]
le moment
et
où
oh
[Musique]
m
tous
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
très vert et blanc à l'orteil un pétale
de paco rabanne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
place des lices si ce cadeau fut la sage
natale
vous préparez dès qu'ils jouent
boulonnaise en avant le talent
[Musique]
non